[Music]
our very own cooking confidence coach my
very own personal cooking confidence
nanny bubby is back in studio thanks to
chapman automotive the sponsors of this
segment today we are learning how to
make roasted vegetable pasta and this is
kind of a continuation it is our last
meeting right we're starting where we
left off which is love in a sheet pan as
i love to call it the roasted vegetables
and we cut them with the night you
taught me how to use knives right right
i think we should go back to that
another time
but what we're going to do here is i'm
going to let you add these vegetables to
a pound of pasta and i'm just going to
talk a little bit about how i cook the
pasta which is this is coming to a
rolling boil rocky and everybody else
you do not want to um add salt until it
comes to a rolling boil and how much
salt not a teaspoon
not two teaspoons just go at it girl
sorry there you go you really want the
water to taste like the c so that is not
too much salt okay just so you know so
that's what we did to this that's a good
tip because usually i just throw it in
there yes right there you go so you're
good you're good all right just i'll
take that from you we'll put it right
there okay so the next thing i want you
to do is i want you to so this spread
love like butter yes i do i want you to
spread love like butter and this i
spread love to you because you have your
own
um
baking baking pan yes nine bites are
every girl every aspiring cook needs a
pyrex dish to cook in and this is yours
you just continue to bless me put a
little butter just there you go go out
there you go there you go there you go
on the sides okay there we go okay let's
talk about the smoke and what is this
doing for
this is so the pasta won't stick okay
okay so now let's put
just this that's good you're real good
all right
i'll take it from you this is a ravioli
sauce which is a spicy marinara right
spicy
now i'm going to let you start mixing
that can you smell that yes i can and
what we're going to do is we're going to
make smoked mozzarella okay so you can't
find smoked mozzarella in the grocery
store really if you bring it home and
you try to shred it yourself it's just
too soft to shred so my hack for that is
taking a hickory smoked olive oil if you
just want to see this over here and then
what you're going to do is just add
about a tablespoon or two into the
mozzarella so
there you go you always have the fancy
olive oil well you know the problem is
is that if you actually try to shred
smoked mozzarella it won't shred and as
i mix this up it just clumps out
i'm a messy mixer but if you can see the
olive oil gets absorbed i'm picking up
from you you're coaching me oh it's not
good
it gets absorbed into the cheese and you
just don't have to worry about it
getting all over the bowl so now you've
got your pasta now you've got your
smoked mozzarella okay okay oh my gosh
all over your ipad but hey if we're not
making a mess we're not having any fun
okay into the bowl there we go start
mixing that honestly i just want to
start eating it already okay a little
bit of salt and pepper i'm going to add
that for you perfect there we go just a
little there we go not as much as in our
pasta water which i think i'll turn off
i don't think i know how okay and then
we're going to add look at that do you
see how good we're adding pieces adding
peas just for fun and color if you don't
like them you don't have to use them but
i love the idea that those are in there
and perfect way to mix your peas in and
hide them from the kids too so now just
to finish it off and yes and hide from
the kids too or hide them from whomever
right so i'm going to let you i will
hold this you start okay
just funneling it in finally there we go
you guys this looks so good oh my gosh
okay now spread it even it out first so
it doesn't go over the edge
okay
that's it oh my god you're doing oh my
gosh you guys look at me and you're gone
i'm a chef yes yes you're not you're not
you're getting less um fearful really
you had like a like i don't want to
touch this i don't want to do that
you're really going at it i'm so proud
of you wow just digging in right use
your instinct your intuition right so
now we're going to sprinkle with
parmesan there we go
and we are going to take a little bit oh
this looks butter
so
i didn't bring a knife but let me just
show you we're going to take little
pieces and chunks of this butter and lay
it on top right good and we're going to
do that i'll finish that up for you i
just want to make a point this does have
a cover but if you don't have a cover
for what you're making you never want to
cover it with aluminum foil aluminum
foil is a great sealer of anything you
want okay but okay anyway off to the
chapman taking notes mental notes
talking to the child
final product because we've got a little
less than 30 seconds
oh careful oh well that's okay
oh my gosh you guys see this oh my gosh
it's beautiful all right here's the
here's a clean spoon so i'm gonna take
this home and i'm gonna get this out of
my oven yeah okay
wow i'm so excited i'm gonna have to
send you a photo
okay
here we go it's hot all right we're
wrapping up here you guys check out
nanny bubby's kitchen and garden on
social media online at nannybubby.com we
also want to thank chapman automotive
for sponsoring this segment jillian i
love live
you guys know i'm hungry